Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750
and see what is on people's minds,
people than we have ever had holding or holding
right now.
Let's go to our caller from the seven five
seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven five seven.
Hi David.
Yes you are.
Who's this?
Oh, my name is Sam.
I'm from Virginia Beach.
Hey sampling.
Cause I just want sure.
A segment that was talking about the, uh,
Democratic primary poles.
Okay.
And, uh, you, uh, talked at length about how
some people were saying all the polls are
biased and all bogus.
And uh, I made a post on your, your reddit
page about it and it was kind of verbose thing.
But, um, the just of it was that the polls
that you referenced in that segment, the thinking
was the main console poll and the Harvard
Harris, the Hill Harris X. Um, we're kind
of an interesting choice because the morning
console polar, she said it was opaque and
didn't really speak to the issue of age in
the polling data, which I think the whole
energy was central to.
But also because the Harvard Harris Poll and
the poll are both conducted, um, uh, owned
by a private equity firm called the stag go
group.
When I started researching into them.
And, uh, the Stag, we'll group kind of a private
equity firm controlled by Mark Penn, who is
a notorious Hillary Clinton strategists and
from form of work in the Bill Clinton administration.
And it's pretty much the democratic establishment.
Well, don't quote.
Would you agree with that characterization?
Uh, I'm not sure about that characterization,
but let me say a couple things just to make
sure we're on the same page.
You know, you called the, the choice of the
polls that I used an interesting choice.
I just used the most recent three poles at
the time that I put the segment together.
So I was going only with the standard of trying
to get the most recent possible data.
So there was no nothing beyond that.
The other thing I think I just, what do you
want to mention to you is that a lot of polling
companies are owned by large corporations,
rich people, et cetera.
And that alone as a disqualifier, I would
be skeptical of,
well it's interesting cause it's stag.
We'll group actually acquired the Harvard
Harris Poll.
She's been running for 50 60 years.
Yeah.
In 2017 after the 2016 primary Harris x, which
is a PR and data consulting company, primarily
consulting with Google, Amazon, and other
companies does ISP in five g technology advertising.
And now all of a sudden they're partnering
with the hill to do this data and it's all,
both of these companies are under the larger
private umbrella of the stag.
Well group, like I said it then it's owned
and founded by Mark Penn.
And like I said, it's so much interesting
just because he chose
those poles.
They also, because the issue seems to be unique
to see polo.
I found a video from March where you talked
about how uh, favoribility poll CNN, uh, actually
excluded younger voters and I believe the
issue that a lot of people writing to you
about what specific to a from CNN in late
April that talked about, we'll have the same
issue with it.
Okay.
That's the poll people were referring to.
Uh, then maybe that's not a good poll.
I haven't looked at that pole, but that wouldn't
change my analysis analysis with the post.
I did look at, uh, in, in any way.
Yeah.
What's fair.
I mean I'm, I'm not trying to say I'm sure
it completely discount the polls because of
the financial backing of whoever is supporting.
Yeah.
Well tell me what you are saying.
I mean, do you think that the three poles
I use, are they just wrong?
Like have they said, let's just give Joe Biden
an extra five, 10 1520 points?
Like what do you think Joe Biden's real level
of support is?
Okay,
well I think it's a little bit weird when
I see polls, assays, 36% of millennials, like
the one that you posted of the heel heterosex
support Joe Biden.
That's just as inconsistent with my experience
of reality,
which is what do you mean how many people?
Like
quarter of a poll, how many people I talked
to?
That's hard to quantify.
Exactly.
But I know they talked to about 500 people
and I probably talked to about the same amount
of people in my day to day life in my social
sphere.
So I feel like it's kind of ridiculous.
And I know this all anecdotal and individual
experience, but I mean 25% of them millennials
are supporting Joe Biden when we have Pete
Buddy Gig, one of the youngest people running,
we got Joe Biden, I mean Bernie Sanders.
He got Kamala Harris,
so you just don't, you just don't believe
the results that you just don't you think
there was a wrong, am I right about that?
Okay.
Not exclusively.
I'm just saying that there's subversive ways
that media companies can influence by select
the fair, let's say Joe Biden's level of support
really is 36% and you don't want Biden to
be the nominee.
What's the best thing that that person should
do?
Okay.
Well I agree with you if you're in this to
make your ultimate youth boot and that we
can't really focus on is to change people's
minds, but I do think that if we choose not
to focus on to funnel the dated media apparatus,
these private equity firms that are buying
the polls and we're, we're, we're kind of
missing the forest for the trees.
We're focusing on the, the, the data, all
the reams of data and specific points, but
we're not looking at the money influenced
that operates on a, on a higher operational
though.
I think a lot of people are looking at that.
I think either way what people have to do
is just go out and vote for the candidate
they, uh, they most agree with.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
I'm gonna let you go because I have so many
people wanting to, wanting to get on.